Julianne's with us in Scranton
Pennsylvania to start this hour off hey
Gillian how are you Oh Dave I am so
excited to talk to you I've tried for
months I swear I'm so excited well I'm
glad you got through how can we help all
right here's a situation my husband and
I when we were married for two years
moved in with an older lady who has no
family he can't afford the house payment
on her own and that was almost seven
years ago since then we've had three
kids and I'm kind of going crazy I feel
like we're you know we're living under a
microscope all the time we're kind of
outgrowing the space
the issue is we still have submit loans
the rent is absolutely unbeatable and if
we leave her she has no one and we help
a lot around the house and things like
that but I mean the house is falling
apart and I don't know I'm just stuck I
don't know what our ethical issues are I
don't know what our you know
responsibilities to her are and I'm just
I just need an outside an outside
opinion and that's why I need to talk I
needed to talk to you well an easy way
to handle most ethics is the simple
golden rule treat other people like you
won't be treated and so if I were this
lady how would I want to be treated well
no one is I'd love for you to stay
because obviously you're taking care of
her and it's a good arrangement for her
but it's uh it's not a good arrangement
for you anymore right it's not a good
long-term plan for you it was a good
short-term plan but it is proven to be a
bad long-term plan and so in that case
if I'm in this lady's shoes I'm gonna
walk a mile in her shoes what would I
want huh I wouldn't want to be surprised
I wouldn't want this to be a shock I'd
want you to give her a good lengthy
notice and during that time during that
time you get your button here and you
use the fact that you got low rent and
you get these student loans paid off
what is your household income well we
work my husband works and I waitress on
the weekends but I don't bring in much
what is your household income about 60
okay and how much student loan debt do
you have
just over 30 Phil okay and how many
children four three three okay and other
debts we don't have any other debt we
own both of our cars and that's it and
what is the and what is the rent that
you're paying this lady we pay 725 a
month okay fine well I would suggest you
get on a budget and get your button gear
and let's get the student loan paid off
and I'm gonna give her about a six month
notice and most of the student loan debt
is going to be gone by the time you
leave okay my husband doesn't
necessarily want me to work more I mean
do I just tell him tough lesson he needs
to learn more than both of you need to
work like crazy people for the next six
months because you're moving out and
your rents going to go up and you need
most of the student loan debt gone by
then right and so you're both gonna have
to work like crazy here's the thing what
you've been doing hasn't been working
right and that includes that that
includes the living there that includes
the income that you create and that
includes the fact you have not been
managing the income you create well
you're not on a tight budget you're not
focused you're not intense on getting
out of debt or you'd be out of debt with
the numbers you gave me seven ranking
years yeah you're right you know so that
tells me that's going on I don't even
have to know I'm not picking on you I'm
just walking with you here I'm on your
team I want you to win so a really tight
budget with great focused intensity
increasing the income give her a six
month notice and that puts you guys on
beed where you get after it
kiddos it's getting really being an
adventure mom and dad are gonna be
working like crazy people and sweet old
lady you need to make other arrangements
because we're going to be leaving at the
six-month mark June the 1st or whatever
I don't care if you want to make it 8
months I don't whatever but you need to
give her a long notice like that and you
use that last little bit as your sprint
out of debt okay who doesn't need a life
this is a weird situation for you it is
it's weird everyone we talked to is like
what yeah it's a head-to you know you
kind of get that German Shepherd thing
so yeah you know I mean it's okay for a
little while but seven years later it's
like wow you got stuck in a rut
so bust out bust out and but you can
give her notice and use it use the last
little bit of time as a sprint and you
know all the weirdness and the lack of
privacy and that kind of stuff can be
tolerated if there's an end to it incite
a date certain that I'm leaving I can
put up with a lot of stuff I mean I live
in a tent if I got a date certain that
I'm out of that tent well probably not
that's an exaggeration but anyway I'm
moving in a tent on this day I'm too old
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you